[Music]
Geronimo
in the dairy market avada cannot only
measure the salinity River Kentucky
[Music]
it's a sideshow that's Shakuni Obama
focus on joy at 30 Misaka taught Iranian
3d camera so now can you eat more
adorable in Ottawa more common in later
steps commonalities the story of our era
you can write with Kira hottest a career
in a colony to crude over energy do not
travel already so troubled
so Marco mosquitoes and touching up
critical Talia - so do we take some you
know commercial women really when
General Tom Burton amino hero no cut
another in a non acidic vodka company
sing-along annoying October turbo
Carrera de su manera toyou know tae-ju
suka schemata no additional Chakri no
katana
Paschal deco logistic so do Sardinia is
to say insanely organised chosen a title
stimulus selection auto shop window
showing medicine
ya know mrs. Potts critical component
you know horrible Anita Mui
you know innovator one of the new Mata
Nui joie de su MO tommy is sonny
language sankarsana Kosovar series on
vehicle ties i know no so much nautical
Addison a society
Pareto you to Matanuska Valley homo
Hong Kong is a useless
[Music]
sighs Oh Demetri no different Tina's
relax and totally immunity no Megan
Ammann Ngongotaha chemistry
Sasha company dr. de combate need mr.
Locke renew my neck my toes tis a new
college Curtis oh no no disabled a
silver brass in la cara Yamato Naruto
Solano Nico - diminished tiny Tom Burton
you WA Ta'ala Cara Muto new details
today whatever is higher altitude Eva
Marcille corner to occur to me Elena
colonization talk with Tim OS a great
demo in a cottage emirate to deliver a
tomboy - Nora amorous warrior
mr. zimble humans in a cottage a Madonna
story will come water insecure wait T
would submerge teams
[Music]
in Japan restaurants and to be clear I
mean a ton of restaurants use plastic
food displays to entice customers and in
google province there's a small factory
that's responsible for more than half of
all the plastic sushi crab omelettes
duck ramen beef oh my god
that's all plastic this is satai kabuki
a watashiwa
sizzle for con us they do a coconut core
Joe Jon Davis this Factory has about 30
full-time artists because all these
plastic foods are made by hand
he Qaida stone or dosa mo mo static
enamel on autism I must know their body
hey super ito yucca so mo no no Hong
Kong di una víctima snow day Aparri
sukadeva mudita Thomas unnimaya ishigami
Takahiro this Takahiro is an artist here
Nanoha tightness on dude opening una had
a title Thomas a Arnone
so no mo no no Tim amis au courant a non
non Monsieur de terre you must know
they're not on any medication on a
canary mistake sorry God to you Iman on
the home of boon Katamari a beautiful
not very much
this trend of plastic food in Japan has
been around since the 1930s but blew up
in the 50s and it is everywhere however
this food it doesn't come cheap
chisaem oh no Lester Amazon very angry
descoteaux more Okemo no petrova a
kombucha Okemah no nutshell tow a GU my
and jus my enter you need enough it's
madness it takes years of training to
master this art sight a demonise on a no
ratio and I thought mo nods good and I
motorist quick example a bowl of ramen
might take three hours to make while a
fish many many more
without worried more children not on
this kiddo uh no sorry no so critical
Atticus over here Mon Ami T Mostow Keiko
a pas de deux even it's good para he no
courtesy you know how - no day a party
so in Minami deokhu this name Akane
hormone only cascaded couple you go
today
you know dr. Kong mighty sovereign even
you know stupid very much she done
attach a photo doc - da light up in
Portobello leaning on opposing Gemini
follow them
so what does you do Kazakh Co gas
station data place transition mode okay
mr. Delatour Inara
so Sigma hajimete Akiko today but the
sumach sorry tangible pacino namaha
sumatera do you eat this koko wa watashi
no oh miss a day Paradise Road
autonomous Ichigo Toa blue Akuma you new
state now study kaizo stay near on
Maduro as they do initially not as you
go to this is a keno Kamaka keyonna so
you know more funding is allocated a
okey Nahanni Chi Janet Iowa caucus
so you Boone cono Anakapalli the sodium
of she dr. see the [ __ ] Mateo no
Leonardo right now meet a noir think you
imagine an enemy hot stove is so common
even ask Alicia talk it is named so we
need the party
Monica Rita y-yo Hasini cannot it's
rated Moloch ready to come in Napoleon
Ivanka in that tick tock listen they
don't don't fall Mishka Jean know some
say Catskill I first Irina Buca that's
Louis key the bone back that a means of
the cara cara job
scoop in order to do you know touchy got
this aura Cara hasta through a community
that God Bogota tea masala Nina not they
think you're gonna need a [ __ ] robots
could tundish Kodomo tachi no cakravaka
rose tuna my name is Kade amo Karuma no
Simon Austin era very mysterious egg at
the American Graffiti so Nona can eat
told you through well you got you know
Matt how could have gotten this
government so color photography amid
encouraging a matamata hot sauce they
have to instead
yeppity-do Cotto meet Ari no no no más
de política look at that you know can
light oka karma Cole you study don't of
combative against me in a need to know
Yokohama Dena I bent over on the speedo
so their motto rider decade an active
yoonjung at Scott Americans I do know
through my become in Nevada the kokino
Dominical agrees Korematsu ago today
achievement Rotorua tommy kaira
haru-nyan is in the rural Mexico
Kane OS tatata ma Rishi Kapoor chroma
Thomas Dumont a cheetah hajimeta no cuz
that's not a boom shake a few Nakada has
amitabh room Cara oh say guys you know
that they look you gotta slow poverty
mmm
don't get tired I never thought in a
million years that I would be here in
Japan singing the music that my
grandmother introduced me to I'm a
testament to say that no matter how big
your dreams are they can definitely be
achieved
[Music]
hey boku no home young age 8 oh my
tonight let's get the more gamey a zero
day in Kakaako
[Music]
ANCA is a form of Japanese music so it's
only song in Japan it is considered an
older genre of music I call it Japanese
blues because all of the lyrics are very
sad melodramatic they often talk about
lost loves and heartbreak it uses a lot
of imagination it really doesn't spell
out the meaning of the song for you
so everyone who listens to the music can
have their own interpretation I was born
and raised in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania my
grandmother she was originally from
Yokohama I basically went to my
grandmother's house just about every
weekend she listened to think music all
the time I think it was a way for her to
keep Japan in her heart even while she
was living in the US I started singing
around five years old my grandmother
would always say you sing so well good
to see a smile on her face would just
brighten my day because I loved her so
much because I had so much love for ANCA
and wanted to know what the lyrics I was
singing meant I started studying
Japanese in high school and throughout
college and was always interested in
Japan and when my mom and my grandmother
came from so I moved to Japan to become
an anchor singer
[Music]
the very first time I stood on the stage
and sang for crowd was actually on TV
kind of like American Idol I was given
so much praise and it made me feel
really really good they were just so
surprised like why would
twenty-something American be listening
to a jar like this and it kind of worked
in my favor I started singing
professionally in 2008 there's never
been an American who's been on stage
singing Anka professionally in Japan
I've had the opportunity to do different
types of songs children's songs musicals
TV dramas I think I've been really
embraced wholeheartedly from the
Japanese audience me singing really was
a way for me to connect to Japan and
connect with my grandmother and to this
day the love I have for ANCA has not
changed
[Applause]
you
seaweed is a common ingredient in
Japanese cuisine but there's a unique
type growing in the Pacific Ocean
[Music]
hobo - Thomas okay now Jessica mother
tonight - she's joined it's Joan among
this 70 miles of the coast of mainland
Japan is the small island of Okinawa
home to one of the most unusual farming
methods in the world what about you got
him I got you about you hold on there
kiddo
mr. Oshiro comes from a seafaring family
and today he is one of the farmers
growing mozuku a special seaweed only
grown in these waters moto moto
fishermen Nagarajan my gray no tsukumo
yogi yeah they take Monaco well as you
hasn't it each fall a web of nets are
laced with Mizzou crew seedlings on land
then mr. Oshiro and his son lay the nuts
in rows in the shallow water this
ingenious system allows the mozuku to
grow sustainably by not creating
additional waste and when the time is
right it is harvested with two boats and
their giant vacuum
[Music]
Sam be a comer to receive oh no Eddie
aha potestas Los Alamos nuclear -
bastard eh they take it to Ankara Tony
Santiago mokey instead it's mock
colonist the day's harvest is then taken
to his factory where it's cleaned
weighed and processed then it's off to
the markets to sell his underwater
treasure
Sam crow activist mozuku is in high
demand
it's packed with nutrients so many
people eat it for a health boost but
that wasn't always the case
mozuku ah Lucas you had a burrito
sunscreen Acosta was you know no kitchen
and grab my car yo no moon color
high-pitched a plan actually the tax on
top of your leptin wha now that Kunis I
cannot understand sir guys unique
musical hero you can all say okay now
Optimus in recent years mr. Oshiro has
seen a change in the ocean so the future
of his mozuku is uncertain cos a cos I
see Menominee neurotic some Coco Sega
juvenility Naito most Gidget Agra you O
Connor
no y'all recognize Terry curry salt and
I know they're against economic system
order to a cancerous ecology through a
pedestrian Oh me no can't yuga yoga
route or Kunwar your romiska scanner
so no tank unit is you know maybe to
attack America toga tableau me Omaha
DeCoteau I got a mother
Nikolai by Megan okay to need cash
tonight oh what a show -
despite the challenges mr. Oshiro
dedication proves this work is more than
just a day job for him it's about
maintaining a family tradition and
passing on his father's respect for the
sea so notice notice on Carnegie Roman
and a host a congregate a culture today
so no it's kappa you don't akuto what i
say madam just throw matter Jubal
Mosconi yep it's true an article
hello attetion of business only see the
criticisms now what I selected every
table so you know sedan is on the slide
in Connecticut
you